how's it going dressed
my name is beer on the path and welcome
to cottage wood period I thought this
week would do a regular relaxing Q&A
just like the good old days huh just
like the good old days but before we do
that I want to ask you Bruce a question
are you a Batman or a Superman fan I'm
personally a huge fan of Batman and I
would love to see him when injustice is
our doing like a voting so you can vote
for who's gonna win at injustice DC
Comics come you can go in there and vote
for Batman and if you're a Superman fan
don't worry don't worry you can still
vote for Batman all right this film is
gross
what's your least favorite word never
just like do just like JB next question
can you make love to a refrigerator I
can make love to anything baby next
question could you show this on Fridays
we keep I know
Oh a next question do you have an
experience with pink toe survive if you
do be a tree well luckily I never had
any oh yeah that's not me ex question
how does being popular feel like I don't
consider myself being popular it's never
something that I wanna be or strive to
be meeting you bros on the street I get
recognized sometimes and that's a really
fun experience i love when you bros say
hi or whatever you want to do and it
makes me feel special
next question how long have you must
have been together almost two years
that's next month thanks for reminding
me
it's in May right next question why does
it creep this way you can say next
question next question next question
laughing the way you never laughed
before that's not really a question but
since you asked so nicely I guess I
can't help it kill me next question do
you ever find all of our celebrities not
really but what I met a like a lot of
youtubers here in Elaine I kind of treat
it as if I already know them and we are
close friends isn't that how it works
you watch someone in YouTube and your
close friends I'm get the memo next
question who inspires you to do videos
can I have a birthday shot
hey hey of course you can have a
birthday shout-out happy birthday man I
think you bros more than anyone inspires
me to do videos that's what makes it fun
for me pretty much if it wasn't for you
bros I wouldn't be making them so keep
doing your thing breasts but keep your
clothes on please next question watch me
tag I got 15 carry pokerface do the same
and that you watch in the video that's
xxxxx xxxxx next question
next question what's up I'll tell you
what's up Matt DX question what can you
do to get more popular on YouTube for
starting youtuber like me the way
YouTube works is really difficult for
people who start off almost too
difficult now and I you know I've been
there I started from zero subscribers
this is everyone else and it's not easy
and I hope I can do another shout-out
channel chat shoutouts challenge soon
because I want I want to help you bro
sama and I know what it's like to be
being not getting the recognition you
deserve next question
my quack-quack my next question do you
think dunks are fabulous question are
you ever had in real jobs I think he
meant if I ever had a real job and thank
thanks for really killing my YouTube
business I'm just kidding I don't feel
like YouTube is a job and I don't want
it to be a job primarily it's just I
want it to be something that you know I
do for fun and that that's that's what
it is still to me I've been working at a
tennis court I work at Harbor lets
Harbor captain for a while captain pewds
how's it going next question do your
best
dinosaur impression my favorite is the
pterodactyl and it's kind of like next
question can you touch your nose with
your tongue finest story um one of the
first like videos way back in the day
waiting before anyone knew who I was I
made a vlog where I what I did this I
think that's one of the first videos
that my girlfriend might see Sony and
apparently it worked the tongue licking
worked wait that sounds wrong next
question alright pros that was all for
today
I know a lot of you brothers one more
business I love doing those more than
anything was eating their really - see
so I think summarization is nice I know
QA maybe is not the most fun thing in
the world but I feel like it brings us
closer together and you you can hear me
talk about myself which is good for my
ego which is ready to explode any second
so I better finish this video I hope you
bros had a great week I would also like
to thank you for 6.5 million girls
already that is just insane where do you
always come from it's ridiculous but so
glad you'll stop by and staying by I
guess I also want to thank you bros for
being understanding this week there has
been a lot less variation there's been a
lot less videos some of you bros know
it's because I'm in LA taking me a lot
of time to settle in I had a lot of
technical issues thank you for being
supported like I said I think from now
on there should be at least two videos
out thanks for staying awesome Rose you
have earned it
now bend over [ __ ] all right here's the
brofist
Oh oh yeah oh btw oh yes see [ __ ]